Democrats are calling on Senate Majority
Leader Mitch McConnell to reconvene the
Senate for an emergency session to
address gun control it's been nearly 15
years since a ban on assault weapons
expired it became law back in 1994 and
it prohibited certain models of ar-15
and ak-47 assault style weapons one
study estimates there are nearly 400
million civilian owned firearms in this
country that's more than any other
country in the world this is the
headline in the conservative newspaper
of the New York Post this morning at the
paper that's generally very friendly to
President Trump it says president Trump
America is scared and we need bold
action it's time to ban weapons of war
Nancy Cordes joins us from Capitol Hill
Nancy what are lawmakers proposing
Anthony's such a tricky issue because
lawmakers from the both sides don't
often agree on the root causes of gun
violence let alone how to address it but
in the wake of this pair of shootings
this weekend we are seeing some overlap
and you had the president that from that
pair of tweets this morning calling for
stronger background checks as Democrats
urged the Senate to break a five-week
recess and come back right away
Congress is paralyzed the Democratic
chorus grew louder last night urging the
Senate's Republican leader to bring
everyone back to Washington we can take
immediate action members of Congress
need to go back to works in the Senate
they want the Senate to take up a
bipartisan bill the House passed in
February mandating universal background
checks for gun sales something 92% of
the American public supports in Ohio and
Texas this weekend key Republicans
signaled they might be open to it
we need background checks to make sure
the wrong people don't have access to
weapons some Republicans called for more
red flag laws that would enable
authorities to detain individuals who
pose a risk to others and confiscate
their guns so all in all this was a
pretty shameful day for Washington after
20 children and six teachers were killed
in Sandy Hook a bipartisan reform bill
fell six votes short when
to send their thoughts and prayers with
no action we say no more but there has
been state-level action in the year
after the mass shooting in parkland
Florida 67 gun safety bills were signed
into law by state legislators those
state laws raised the gun purchasing age
from 18 to 21 enacted waiting periods
and limited the size of magazines and
there has been some action here in
Washington as well after the shootings
in Las Vegas that left 57 people dead
the Trump administration limited the use
of bump stocks which make weapons more
deadly so there has been some change
dareka but both sides agree probably not
enough Nancy I can't help but think
about that 400 million civilian owned
firearms no matter how many laws pass
that's a lot of guns in people's hands
Nancy thank you